これじゃあ肇社長です皆さんカツサンド
好きですか僕は前科2案とそんな好きじゃないんですよまあ喰う客いますけどそんな
勝さん動産の行っちゃう高であると思うんですけどもカツサンドって皆さん誰相場なん
いねえだと思いますか
まぁだいたい300400500万強くても700ひどくて1000円とかだと思うん
ですけども
紅葉
の中に今
よってますねまぁこの世の中にはそんな価格だと抑えきれないような豚なは内閣の格差
のあるんです
こっちええなぁこちら和牛マフィアってお店のカツさんなんですけどもこっちらが
とんでもない値段なんですよまた見た目を見てくださってやばいすごい
まあまあこれなんか何と経度入ってのこれ g ショックをて月
までもすぐ高級そうなんですけどこちらお値段なんと
50,000円
とかおっさんだ
ありません5万円ですよそんなカツサンドある子はこんなに5番入っていいですよね
待って5万円だったら何回で立
行けるか分からんですというわけで早速5万円な3-1見ていきたいとおもいます
明けまあ
[音楽]
いきましょうん
はい
ふぇっ
金が乗っ取り屋ゲーということ私をはじめとしたか超えてると思うんですよ日本はて
達観いろんなものを食べてきました今いろんなカツサンドを準備してますで目隠しして
もたぶん僕の下だと5万円のカツサンドぐらいわかると思ってたんで5万円のさっ
ちゃんですよ
摩れに分かると思うんですと言われて今日の動画は5万円の拡散と目隠ししてもさすが
にはから雪
やって
いきたいと思いますで嘘おっぱいというわけで5万円のカツサンドを含めた5種類の
山道準備いたしました
まず最初のなカメルーン代表と5さん
うわああああああ
えっ使ってええええ
もっとも馴染みがあるのじゃない魂麺のサーフ1
スーパーあるといったことはありませんまあ
nao
nan
上手いってどうか僕知りませんでしたじゃーんっはぁっ
原発がそんなあるのが全くない
マグーまんがぁああ
でこっから僕は目隠しでちょっとくっていくんですけども5万円月だとあのわかるん
ですよねカーズとも食わずともそんな高いもマジ顔根本的に違うと思うんでアームも
始め無しで普通に食っても置かなかったのかっ
だってのがわかると思うんでパソですこれすごく寒いよってまあその晩ええじゃないか
5万円7傾げ圧術ておりますがお願いします
よって僕は5万円がわかるかどうかなんてよってでもベロベロお酒が弱い僕で5万円の
花摘んだばかり言ったらもうさすがに5万円といったところなんでしょうね
さぁどっち金でください
ハアハアハア
ん
だってわかんないんだけどでも俺の人生切ってんだろた5万円の拡散のって今まで食べ
たことのないてくれだと思うんですよなんでこの漢字
何か食べたことあるんですよねこれ
なんで割とし犯的なものだと思います今だめだサンドイッチは5万円の3-1ではあり
ません
世界にさあ知らせずあずこれって何とかこれはコンビニのサンドイッチですね
だから食べたことだったのか
ボーマンいってお母さん本土も見られたからもう寝るんですか
足はサーファーさんもうすごいをウサギでも奴でも多かなぁ
ん
パンがパサパサしている5万円ではありません
世界上がった矢部やったかと思っていますとにこれはディスカウントショップの
サンドイッチという
ディスカウントショップって何ですか時法廷でスペだろ
四谷3本目お願いしますいつ来てもいいじゃ本当にもこれで
待ってうまいなぁ混ざっえっこれか
おっと a わかんないまずはめちゃくちゃおいしいぞ a 1ては関大本当に雨が
すごい味に深みのあるんですよね
こうがこれは5万円家庭じゃないんですよね肉厚
食べやすさ
生地の柔らか3そしてほのかに香る
中身だ君行き届いましたはい
私が今食べたさんと市は
5万円のサンドイッチです
ざんねんっ
今食べたのこちらですねスーパーの31です幸せな人生
[音楽]
me
そうでしょマジっすかめっちゃ美味しかったですよ5万円と語るよっ
ね本当に恥ずかしい続きましょうと思いますんで
させるにもうに便所になってますよおすすめお願いします
はい早めバイそうでしたおっはいはい
[音楽]
5番
もういいですか正解ですすぐわかった
えっ
すごいすごいベッソンないですけどは高級感がしました
バッグを9時の広がり方なぁきんたろぐわーってくるっ
yeah
うんまというわけでですねさすがに5万円ねえと分かったんですけども
スーパー-3-1町僕は5万円だと感じがしてたんで
結局はねぇ
想像力で何でも5万円になるって事ですよさん人生を受けみましょう
happy new year